bonjour après un épisode pas très gai
sur les revenants j'ai décidé de rester
dans l'imaginaire médiéval
parce que je trouve intéressant
d'étudier comment penser et ce que
pensaient les contemporains de la
période qu'on étudie en plus on approche
de la période de noël
et qui dit noël dit coin frery banquet
et qui dit banques et eddy qu'adapter
indigestion
non aliénor tu devrais le savoir en plus
c'est ta période a alors banques et du
faisan
c'est aussi le titre de l'épisode le
pays de cocagne
[Musique]
le pays de cocagne fait partie du
folklore de l'imaginaire médiéval au
moins depuis le 13ème siècle au milieu
du xiiie siècle apparaît la plus
ancienne version écrite du mythe de
cocagne mais il est probable que cette
histoire est d'abord été transmise à
l'oral d'ailleurs plus qu'un mythe
la cocaïne peut être vu comme une utopie
puisqu'elle offre un contre modèle à la
société médiévale
d'autres historiens y voit un rêve
compensatoires ou encore un monde à
l'envers
un peu plus sympathique que celui de
stranger tides comme je le disais plus
tôt le premier texte conservé évoquant
le pays cocagne est écrit au milieu du
xiiie siècle en picardie ils sont passés
des choses en picardie à l'époque le
texte s'appelle le fab lio de cocagne il
s'agit d'un poème de 188 vers racontant
le voyage merveilleux de l'auteur vers
ce pays imaginaire un fabliau à cette
époque est un genre littéraire qui
apparaît vers le milieu du 12e siècle et
traitent parfois de thèmes quotidien
parfois de merveilleux avec une morale à
la clé dans ce fabliaux plusieurs thèmes
principaux se dégagent alors je vais
laisser aliénor lire le premier extrait
que nous pourrons commenter juste
ensuite
attention le passage qui va suivre
risque de vous donner faim de bar de
saumon et dalloz sont les murs de toutes
les maisons les chevrons sont
d'esturgeons des toitures de l'art et
les clôtures de saucisses beaucoup plus
existe aux pays de dellys car de rôti et
de jambon son enclos les champs de blé
par les rues vont se retissent an de
grâce aux oies qui tourne sur elle même
arrosé d'une blanche sauce à l'ail je
vous dis que partout sur les chemins et
des rues on trouve des tables dressées
avec des nappes blanches ou peuvent
boire et manger tous ceux qui veulent
gracieusement sans contredit et sans
interdiction
chacun prend tout ce que son coeur
souhaitent certains du poisson d'autres
de la viande
si quelqu'un veut remplir un char il le
fera à son gré viande de cerf ou
d'oiseaux volent en rôti ou en ragoût il
ne payera pas d'économies après avoir
mangé c'est ainsi qu'on fait au pays je
feins si on m'avait décès lire
n'inquiète pas le prochain tome 2
correspond tout à fait la première idée
qu on retrouve dans ce pays de cocagne
et donc la nourriture
l'abondance la boustifaille évidemment
ce n'est pas anodin
la fin est une grande préoccupation au
moyen-âge à cause des pénuries
alimentaires voire des famines après
l'an mil on retrouve encore des famines
régional récurrentes
j'ai faim ah tiens
philippe l'autre raison pour laquelle
l'alimentation est une grande
préoccupation au moyen âge c'est qu'il
ya quand même 70 jours de jeunes dans le
calendrier chrétien ça creuse du coup en
cocagne on ne fait pas cas sous vers sa
fin on se contente pas des deux repas
par jour de la société médiévale et le
car elle n'a lieu que tous les 20 ans le
reste du temps on mange on mange on
mange abondance pour tous les hollandais
appelle d'ailleurs la cocagne terre de
la paresse et de la goinfrerie et
plusieurs choses sont intéressantes à
noter sur les aliments site est déjà
selon les versions la cocagne on trouve
pas les mêmes aliments en france les
maisons sont faites en poissons et en
viande mais en italie on trouve des
maisons en fromage avec des rues en
lasagnes et en allemagne elles sont en
légume un fruit un champignon et bien
sûr on trouve du vin de la bière de
l'hydromel de l'eau-de-vie parce qu'on
parle quand même du pays capable de
boire son poids en bière à chaque
oktoberfest ensuite on retrouve dans la
plupart des aliments cité des produits
consommés par la classe supérieure
c'est là qu'on va faire un point cuisine
médiévale donc j'insiste prenez un
goûter le pain est absent de la cocagne
alors que c'était juste la base de
l'alimentation médiéval avec au moins un
demi kilo consommé par jour et par
personne
il est donc beaucoup trop commun pour
figurer en cotant de même les habitants
de la cocagne était très loin des 5
fruits et légumes par jour là encore les
nobles en consommer très peu alors
pourquoi se forcer
en plus si le récit de la cocagne est
originaire de picardie
il y avait plein de légumes là bas
tellement qu'on en était écoeuré alors
est ce qu'on veut vraiment encore dans
notre paradis gustatif n'ont pas de
fromage non plus alors qu'à partir du
11e siècle apparaissent de nombreux
fromages bien connu de nos contrées
comme le roquefort le bris le gruyère le
parmesan etc
il est de plus en plus populaire mais
surtout associé aux fous aux pauvres et
considéré comme peu sain par la médecine
a dégagé on ne trouve pas non plus des
pis encore gagne tout semble être
naturellement bon sens besoin de sauce
et d'aromates comme ma cuisine il est
aussi possible que puisque beaucoup des
peas avait des vertus médicinales elle
soit absente de la cocagne parce qu'on
est on jamais malade de toute manière
ben alors qu'est ce qu'on mange
là c'est si vous êtes végétarien ça va
pas le faire
en cocagne on mange surtout de la viande
plein de viande la viande était très
importante au moyen-âge
à tel point que le mot viande était
parfois synonymes d'aliments on trouve
surtout du porc la viande la plus
courante au moyen âge parce qu
accessible à tous mais aussi de la
volaille avec des oies qui se promène
tout seul dans les rues en retissant
tout seul et aussi du gibier avec le
sert et les oiseaux volants étrangement
toutes les viandes cités sont assez
populaire contrairement aux aliments
précédent on mange aussi des poissons à
partir du 11e siècle la pisciculture
devient très importante
il existe même une législation royal
2289 visant à freiner la pêche pour
permettre la régénération des fleuves en
plus il y avait 146 jours maigres dans
le calendrier chrétien des jours où la
consommation de viande était interdite
du coup on y mangeait du poisson frais
si c'était du poisson d'eau douce et
salée aux fumées si c'était du poisson
de mer rapport à l'absence de frigo pour
accompagner ces repas on trouve surtout
des vins mais pas d'eau parce qu'à
l'époque seuls ceux qui n'avaient pas
les moyens de s'acheter du vin se rabat
et sur la bière le lait ou au pire l'eau
par contre pas de dessert quoi mais j'ai
rien fait au xiiie siècle on servait des
plats sucrés à la fin des repas parce
qu'on pensait que ça faciliter la
digestion
comment cocagne on est de toute façon
jamais malade pas besoin de sucre à
schwedt rights watch est qu'une brique
fest la cocagne est aussi une terre de
fainéants de sinik d'oise if ce pays a
pour don cocagne plus on y dort plus on
y gagne celui qui dort jusqu'à midi
gagne 5 sous et demi là un mois à six
semaines
un an à 4 packs et quatre fêtes de saint
jean une année 1,4 vendanges tous les
jours fériés et dimanches 4 toussaint 4
noël 4 chandler 4 carnaval et un carême
tous les 20 ans quand il est agréable de
jeunes et le pays est si riche que des
bourses pleines de denis et xixe le long
des champs marc avait dit et besançon
trouver partout inutile la personne
n'achète ni ne vend l'oise yves telle
est la seule activité rémunérée en
cocagne qui s'appelle d'ailleurs en
allemand et il est paresseux et des fous
l'argent j'y au bord des chemins pense
qu'il ne sert de toute façon à rien les
fabliaux reprennent souvent ce thème de
l'oise yves thé et du repos parce que
dans la société médiévale le travail
reste longtemps associé à la pénitence
travailler en ancien français garde son
sens initial de souffrir
ce qu aux xvième siècle et on le
retrouve encore dans l'italien travail à
aller qui signifie tourmente et torturé
alors que le verbe italien pour dire
travailler se dit l'avocat
c'est pour ça qu'en cocagne ont fait la
fête le temps n'évolue pas puisqu'il n'y
a pas de famille pas de génération pas
de roi pas de calendrier
du coup les fêtes de noël de saint jean
baptiste et même les vendanges perdent
leur sens premier et redeviennent liées
aux anciennes fêtes païennes et
paysannes dans le cas des vendanges pas
besoin de ramasser du raisin puisque le
vin coule à flots mais les vendanges
était surtout l'occasion de bonne fête
campagnarde qui marquait la fin des
travaux des champs les fête de la
cocagne s'apparentent surtout au
carnaval et à la fête des fous par
exemple toujours en picardie les fête
des fous pouvait durer un mois et on y
trouvait 7 ou 8 ans fort durant
lesquelles les rôles étaient inversés
dans les villes qu'il est pratiqué
malgré l'interdiction de l'église et du
roi les chants religieux été remplacés
par des chansons obscène des enfants
exercé des fonctions de commandement et
des prêtres pouvez lancer des boudins
sur la foule
la cocagne est aussi un pays libre tout
le monde est libre de coucher avec
n'importe qui mais il n'y a pas de
naissance parce que ça empêche de faire
la fête
il n'y a que des adultes en cocagne au
xvième siècle certains récits imagine un
arbre nous tomberait les êtres humains
lorsqu'il serait mûr avec des vêtements
qui les attendrait au sol
cette liberté sexuelle est un petit
tacle à l'église qui inscrit à partir du
12ème siècle le mariage parmi les sept
sacrements
à partir de là on ne déconne plus le
mariage est considéré comme une union
hétérosexuelle monogame et indissoluble
les relations sexuelles ne sont plus
permise que dans le cadre du mariage
seulement la nuit dans une seule
position et un tiers à un quart des
jours de l'année parce que le reste du
temps le calendrier chrétien l'interdît
enfin la cocagne est une terre
d'éternelle jeunesse grâce à la fontaine
de jouvence
il ya encore une autre merveille vous
jamais n'écouta chose pareille la
fontaine de jouvence qui rajeunit les
gens et apporte d'autres bienfaits là il
n'y aura pas je le sais bien d'hommes si
vieux aussi fleuri ni de femme si
vieille aux cheveux blancs aux cris zone
ans qui ne retrouve ses 30 ans si à la
fontaine ils peuvent aller là peuvent
rajeunir ceux qui habitent le pays
la vieillesse était mal perçue dans la
société médiévale sur toute l'espérance
de vie était bien plus courte que de nos
jours à cause de la forte mortalité
infantile c'est pourquoi on retrouve
également dans le fab lio le proverbe
suivant si les barbus étaient des sages
book et chèvres le seraient aussi donc
inversement la jeunesse est une grande
préoccupation
par contre pour l'aristocratie médiévale
être jeune ne renvoyait pas forcément à
l'âge mais plutôt au fait d'être
célibataire et sans enfant forêt
d'orient pourrait donc être le cri de
ralliement des childfree dans la plupart
des versions de la cocagne
ses habitants ont été réellement 30 ans
ce qui par un formidable le hasard est
aussi lâche symbolique d'adam et de
jésus dans d'autres versions ils ont 10
ou 20 ans on connaît maintenant les
principaux thèmes du fabliaux de la
cocaïne mais qu'il a écrit précisément
on ne sait pas trop juste qu'il écrivait
en picardie au milieu du xiiie siècle et
qu'il était cultivé dans son premier
manuscrit il dit qu'il s'est inspiré
d'un texte antérieur mais on ne sait pas
si c'est la réalité ou s'il dit ça pour
donner un peu plus de légitimité à son
discours je vais écrire une histoire
fantastique original oh tu prends des
risques que non je vais écrire un remake
au mais oui elle était bien cette
histoire
la version sera forcément bonne aussi
quoi qu'il en soit il fait référence à
des monnaies du 12e siècle qui sont
actualisées dans les versions suivantes
les noms des monnaies et des tissus
changent selon les versions et selon les
pays
l'auteur était donc peut-être un
trouvère un poète qui chantait des
poésies de la cour d'amiens ou de coucy
ou alors ils pouvaient être un golliard
les colliard sont souvent des étudiants
pauvres itinérant le genre de personne à
aimer festoyer et boire les écrivait des
chansons à boire et aussi des poèmes
satiriques qu'il déclamait lors de fêtes
de village
leurs écrits étaient le plus souvent en
latin al'inverse des fabliaux mais on en
trouve aussi en français et en allemand
donc trouvèrent hugo liard on ne sait
pas trop on ne sait pas non plus s'il
s'adressait à un public aristocratique
puisque les personnages des crises
semblent être des aristocrates ou à des
bourgeois des villes ou encore à des
paysans même si ça semble moins probable
pour en savoir un peu plus sur le
personnage
on peut s'intéresser à ce qu'il décrit
vraiment dans le fabliaux pourquoi at-il
écrit la cocagne et que voulait-il
parodier ou critiquer à travers son
oeuvre
il existe des tas d'hypothèses déjà dans
son éloge de l'abondance de la liberté
et du farniente ça revienne c'est ne
rien faire ils critiquent pas mal
l'église et la société
merci captain obvious la société
médiévale à partir du 12ème siècle voit
fleurir d'état d'administration de
réglementation la société est donc de
plus en plus encadré et met en valeur le
travail c'est vraiment d'heure mais le
vrai monde il va chez le coiffeur
l'église en fait de même en condamnant
le métier d'usuriers qui revient à
gagner de l'argent en ne faisant rien la
cocagne proteste face à tout ça dans son
éloge de l'abondance elle critique aussi
l'église qui place la passion de manger
parmi les sept péchés capitaux
grossière erreur et comme en cocaïne on
aime manger n'est pas travailler tout ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire on n'y trouve
aucun outil et les aliments se cuisent
tout seul en réalité moi non plus je ne
fais rien et je ne cuisine jamais ça
n'est pas très compliqué pour toi ce
thème d'une société libertaire contre
une église un peu trop dur est aussi
repris dans le combat de carnaval et
karen de rabelais illustré en peinture
par bruegel
il est possible que la cocaïne décrivent
aussi une abbaye de jeunesse
à l'époque il s'agissait de groupes de
jeunes dans les villes qui organisait
des festivités
si on reste dans l'hypothèse que la
cocagne décrit une scène urbaine une
autre idée évoque le lien avec les
confréries et les guildes de métier à
l'époque il s'agissait de groupes
sociaux de personnes qui exerçait le
même métier dans le même quartier
ils s'entraident et grâce à des levées
de fonds et surtout prenez des repas
ensemble organiser des jeux des fêtes
etc
ainsi la cocaïne pourrait être une
allégorie de la cérémonie d'initiation
dans une confrérie ou en jean
plus encore elle pourrait être une
critique des guilde moderne qui
monopolisent de plus en plus la vente et
la production
encore une fois elle fait l'éloge de la
liberté là où la société médiévale se
complexifier de plus en plus et supprime
la séparation entre public et privé
en gros c'est une société anarchiste
tout à fait mais une utopie qui n'évolue
pas puisque ses membres ne vieillissent
pas et qui n'est pas réalisable parce
que les oies ne se promèneront jamais
dans les rues en retissant tout seul
et heureusement puisque le personnage
principal de la cocaïne dit être arrivé
là bas pour y faire pénitence
il est possible que ce fabliaux fasse
référence à un pèlerinage au hasard le
pèlerinage le plus en vogue à l'époque
était jérusalem une croisade comme vous
l'appelez aujourd'hui ce serait donc le
récit d'un personnage parti en croisade
théorie qui peut être renforcée par la
présence de monet orientale dans le
fabio qui découvrirait un monde d une
culture totalement inconnu qui en
reviendrait tout chambouler du coup la
fontaine de jouvence pourrait être
associé au christ ou au saint sépulcre
est dans un registre beaucoup moins
exotique le fabricant pourrait être une
représentation de l'au delà
au passage merci de m'avoir transformer
en squelette selon le précédent épisode
j'apprécie le geste le voyageur
parviendrait dans l'au-delà par une
sorte de vous
agnostique appelé visio à cette époque
mais serait incapable de le retrouver
une fois retourné dans le monde réel
moi aussi je peux tenter une théorie
vas-y après tout c'est toi la plus
contemporaine c'est une taverne
évidemment je suis de toi dans les
tavernes on mange on boit et on se
retrouve entre jean marginaux et
personnes qui ont fini leur journée des
gens oisifs quoi il ya énormément de
taverne dans le nord de la france à
cette époque et je le sais je les ai
toutes testées par exemple il y en a 130
à paris en 1292 plus que des boucheries
et les boulangeries
et il y en avait environ 200 à londres
au 14e siècle alors qu'il n'y avait que
40 mille habitants et il y en a
tellement qu en 1256 louis 9 après en
avoir interdit l'accès à ces hommes
déclarent que toutes les personnes qui
fréquentent des tavernes son infâme est
interdite de témoigner devant la justice
bizarrement sac loi n'est pas appliquée
dans les tavernes on fait aussi des
choses sérieuses comme venir des oeuvres
de l'antiquité ou raconter des récits
folklorique c'est donc le lieu parfait
pour mélanger toutes ces influences et
en faire le fabricant justement quelles
sont les influences du fabliaux etc at
il influencé ensuite l'imaginaire du
pays de cocagne n'est pas apparu tout
seul il emprunte à des mythes de
l'orient ancien du monde gréco-romain
des juifs des celtes des scandinaves des
musulmans des chrétiens et cetera
c'est déjà pas mal et là je ne les
citerai que certaines des influences
possible parce qu'il y en a des tas dans
l'épopée de gilgamesh écrite vers 2500
avant jésus-christ le personnage
principal
gilgamesh recherche la plante de la
jeunesse et de l'immortalité
on y trouve aussi la description d'un
déluge pendant lequel il pleut abondance
et saint boiseau bancs de poissons
profusion de blé pas de la pluie du tout
quoi toujours chez les mésopotamiens la
terre de 10 mo serait une région riche
en récolte et à l'abri des maladies et
de la mort chez les grecs
hésiode et platon raconte le mythe de
l'âge d'or repris par les romains
ensuite une époque bénie où on ne
connaît pas la vieillesse un éternel
printemps au cou et des ruisseaux de 20
sur l'île des bienheureux le bonheur on
retrouve aussi une fontaine de jouvence
chez les grecs dans la caméra se
gagnerait tous les ans pour retrouver sa
virginité
chez les 7 le chaudron d'abondance et le
panier de greene nos gars amir pouvait
nourrir la terre entière
on y retrouve aussi une fontaine de
jouvence la fontaine la valeur et le
pays mythique de tir na nog où tout le
monde reste éternellement jeune ça ne
les a pas empêchés de se faire envahir
par vos troupes
chez les scandinaves
le valhalla se rapproche du mythe de la
cocagne puisqu'on y mangent chaque jour
la viande du sanglier s'aérer venir qui
reste entier malgré tout les racines de
l'hydrazine l'arbre monde aurait aussi
des propriétés de jouvence bref beaucoup
de mythes ont pu inspirer la cocagne et
la cocagne a été reprise un nombre
incalculable de fois après sa première
écriture on la retrouve en français mais
aussi en anglais allemand gaélique
italiens hollandais finnois suédois
russes etc
en angleterre le poème anglais de la fin
du xiiie siècle de la hand of cooking
s'inspire de son homologue français mais
l'adapter à soc dans le monastère de
cocagne qui se trouve sur une île au
large de l'espagne
mais moi dans l'habitude de voler
jusqu'à des religieuses qui se baignent
nus dans un fleuve jusqu'à ce que la bd
rappel en ta porte sur les fesses d'une
jeune fille pour les ramener au sol
le monastère est aussi construit en
aliments et pour se rendre sur cette île
il faut rester baigner dans des
excréments de porcs pendant sept ans en
théorie on risque pas trop dit arrivé
par hasard à l'époque moderne le récit
de la cocagne évolué au lieu d'une
joyeuse description des moeurs urbaine
le récit de la cocagne et de cette fois
une critique de la société qui émane
plutôt dépaysant la cocaïne devient
gouverné par un roi bouchons qui
s'appelle pas niveau il s'appelle
comment alors juste panique ont en plus
la société se retrouve à nouveau avec
quelques dizaines bien senti pendant la
guerre de trente ans par exemple pour
beaucoup de contemporains de l'époque
moderne
on mangeait mieux avant au moyen-âge
donc s'imaginer une société d'abondance
fait du bien un autre indice qui nous
montre que la cocaïne devient populaire
et l'apparition du mât de cocagne
il s'agit d'un jeu organisé pendant les
fêtes de mai pendant lequel on enduit un
tronc de graisse et les personnes
doivent grimper au sommet pour récupérer
les aliments qui se trouve tout en haut
ce jeu est encore parfois pratiqué au
brésil où le mythe de cocagne est
apportée par les portugais et dans le
village de saint félix de l'orage et qui
pratique encore une fête de cocaïne tous
les ans pour finir la cocagne est une
utopie très différente des autres
utopies de l'époque moderne
on va citer l'utopie de thomasz mort au
xvième siècle celle de thomas second
panel là et la nouvelle atlantide de
francis bacon toutes les deux au xviie
siècle
dans ces trois utopie c'est pas
franchement la même rigolade dans celle
de campanella les repas ont des menus
défini et son prix en silence et dans la
nouvelle atlantide les repas ne dure
qu'une heure trente
et pas question d'oisiveté dans ces
utopies là
pour que la terre deviennent fertile il
faut travailler ces sociétés sont aussi
gérontocratique c'est à dire al'inverse
de la cocagne gouverné par des vieux
parce que les vieux c'est vachement
disent non le mariage est aussi une
institution importante par exemple sur
l'île de thau masse morts deux adultes
r&c la peine de mort la peine de thomas
dans l'europe moderne la cocagne est de
plus en plus mal vu ce n'est pas une
vraie utopie puisqu'elle n'a jamais été
réalisable ne prône pas un retour vers
le passé mais plutôt une évasion vers un
monde à l'envers où tout est possible et
est associée aux révoltes populaires et
paysannes même les humanistes ne la
trouve donc pas très respectable et
préfèrent s'intéresser au mythe de l'âge
d'or par exemple dans le conte allemand
d'hansel et gretel des frères grimm la
maison en pain d'épicé s'inspirer des
bâtiments de la cocaïne devient à
l'heure pour attirer les enfants à la
sorcière danger donc la cocagne inspire
quand même certains artistes de l'époque
moderne
rabelais la reprend dans la bataille de
carême et de carnage qui décrit un petit
village oisifs et dans son abbaye de
thélème bosch la reprend aussi dans son
jardin des délices à la fin du 16ème
siècle à cocagne est très présente dans
l'économe graphie surtout italiennes
hollandaises allemandes bruegel l'ancien
et bruegel celui d'après la peine
également mais brüderle en dresse un
portrait plutôt négatif puisque les
personnages ont l'air lourd et assoupi
tellement et n'ont rien fait de leur
journée à part manger et je termine avec
archim baldocchi en matière de
représentation de l'abondance
alimentaire se pose là avec le tableau
du cuisinier par exemple ou de
l'horticulteur qui se disent dans les
deux sens
comme cette vidéo si vous la repasser à
l'envers vous verrez que n'importe quoi
toi bref cet épisode est maintenant
terminée et comme d'habitude j'espère
qu'il vous a plu parce que c'est un
petit peu plus mais puisque les
médiévaux et je m'inclus dedans été un
petit peu con quand nous voyons des
cornes de nerval flotter dans les seules
dans les eaux à dans les cieux j'ai dit
à monsieur mais dans les cieux ce sont
bien évidemment les baleines qui vole
donc quand nous voyons des cornes de
licorne fauté dans les eaux qui étaient
en fait des narvals et bien nous
pensions que c'était des licornes et
c'est ainsi que les experts j'en profite
pour rappeler si vous n'avez pas regardé
mon blog parce que les blogs sont
toujours moins intéressant que j'ai un
nouveau moyen de financement qui
s'appelle your type et qui vous permet
de me financer sans rien débourser
puisque vous avez juste à regarder des
pubs
bref je vous renvoie à ce site où vous
trouverez toutes les informations
nécessaires à son utilisation
si vous le voulez
j'ai aussi un tipi le toujours bien le
rappeler et surtout l'information
principale est qu'il y aura une autre
vidéo qui sortira durant ce mois de
décembre sur ma chaîne toujours en
histoire et voilà ça sera bien donc à
bientôt et bon mois de décembre jusqu'à
ce qu'on se retrouve au revoir tellement
un chat noir immense marché sur les
toits de la ville et détruire toutes les
cheminées voilà je crois que c'est bon
il à sa fille mais pas le port de balès
elle s'est laissé les fans de omaha hi
lo cor de chasse et les hôpitaux locaux
ont pris peur
elle portera au cow boy next time i were
superbike au point de menacer les
alentours du port de balès *
saint-gobain
ça c'est le poker ahmed bani